okay seeing that it is 10 30 a.m i'm
going to call to order the uh
subcommittee work session for house bill
hb 1454 fn
uh and with that i don't have a gavel
but i'll just use my hands so we'll open
the subcommittee work session
just to briefly talk about where we were
last week we had some
conversation around potential changes
and tweaks and language
we heard from representative tucker
and director wimsat a little bit about
some of the varying geological
structures
throughout the state and with that i'd
like to briefly open
and allow representative tucker to come
forward and just give us an update with
any changes she may have had and then
i'll
open the floor to the subcommittee work
group members to continue um
with where our work
thank you
yours
well thank you
for being here today
uh
i really don't have much to add uh
various members of the committee
your committee have been working
and some last minute thoughts of coming
up so i think that things are still
bubbling along as people try to get this
just right on my way down here i stopped
in the town of carroll which i represent
made up of twin mountain and
bretton woods
and saw that last year at their timing
they voted 202 to 75
against having a landfill in dalton
at their town meeting
which is an sb2 town so
they discuss it
previous to that meeting
the town of whitefield did the same but
the previous year by a much more
overwhelming
margin and i wanted to bring that up
because
i think it's good to know that people
who live in the area
where there's a current
pending
partial application
do have opinions on the topic
and
really i'm eager to hear what you have
to say i'm eager to get something in the
hands of
ols
so they can move forward so i thank you
enormously
thank you representative tucker i am
going to also let the folks um and the
public know that there are copies of
proposed language um
as presented by representative bixby i
think they're at the end of the table
here if you'd like to grab them feel
free to do so
and with that i'm going to
open it up for discussion among the
subcommittee work group members
representative bixby
um
oh sorry
uh
actually and representative bixby in my
error may i pause for a moment
okay
i just wanted to make sure that i also
recognized that there is a member of the
actual subcommittee work group who had a
thought in my apologies to the member so
just one but go ahead okay so um so the
uh
the pre so that the first sentence
basically says why this uh
uh why this piece of legislation is in
the public interest and
uh
emphasizes that
preventing that it's really about
preventing
contamination from reaching the
perennial water bodies
uh
the uh
and then a period of five years should
be sufficient to detect and map a
failure assess appropriate remediation
meet engineering and regulatory
requirements and initiate a remedy uh
so um
and i see i spelled it misspelled
initiate there but that's something we
can do in drafting um
so uh
the
so that basically
sets the framework for
what follows and then what follows is
pretty much uh what we uh were
discussing last week
and uh i have removed from the middle of
the fir of the next paragraph
the words any leaks bill or other
failure because that uh
was
a cause of confusion for people reading
it and we certainly don't want
legislation to be confusing
so
the
so this basically sets out uh
the policy of uh you know how how this
is um how this goes together and then
paragraph b
sets out uh
what the
basically how the policy will be
implemented
so um
uh so
the
fundamental idea behind this is that
before
anybody wants to
cite a landfill
if they do this assessment and figure
out that yes
this is a this is a viable sort of site
based on hydrogeology then it makes
sense for them to go forward if they
discover that
that their
intended site may fail this test then
they having done this at the very
beginning they will realize that this is
not a good place to sign a landfill and
they can look for look elsewhere
so that that's the basic idea here
so
and i'm happy to
well i guess uh representative compton
had some thoughts please
representative
thank you madam chair i do have some
questions and a couple of concerns
um
and i guess my first question will be
for director winsett
if you don't mind
currently
how many public landfills do we have in
the state of new hampshire that accepts
from other towns i guess is the question
because you have local
landfill sites that only accept from
their town but then you have the ones
that accept from other towns that don't
have a landfill site
right right now we have only three
municipally owned landfills that are
operating
nashua
just takes from nashua
lebanon takes from a limited service
area that includes about uh
i don't know eight or ten
towns in the area of lebanon in new
hampshire and another
maybe eight or ten towns in vermont so
they have the limited service area but
they do take about waste from about 20
towns both in new hampshire and vermont
and then the mount washington um
valley landfill in conway
and i they take from conway north conway
i believe they may be albany and a
couple of other towns so there are a few
other but again a limited service area
and then um
there's always a great category so the
anderson valley regional refuge disposal
district owns and operates the mount
carvery landfill and success
so that's not maybe technically a
municipally owned landfill but it's a
publicly owned landfill it's owned by a
district
and they operate commercially and they
have an unlimited service area so they
accept waste from
all over new hampshire um and
massachusetts maine and uh and vermont
and and they could they couldn't take
waste from anywhere
anywhere they'd like they have unlimited
service area
um are there any other public landfills
um in new hampshire i mean is there one
in rochester i believe and that's not a
public landfill the rochester landfill
is owned by waste management in new
hampshire it's called the turnkey
landfill
and that is a commercially operated
landfill that accepts waste from from
with an unlimited service area
and then the uh to round it out uh
what's the only one i haven't mentioned
is the ncs landfill in bethlehem which
is also a privately owned commercially
operated landfill with an unlimited
service area
um
thank you and and
director wins said of the commercially
run
or
landfills which is mount carbury turnkey
and the ncs in bethlehem
what is the life expectancy on each of
those
the current permitted capacity
in
rochester at the turnkey landfill they
are permitted to operate through 2034.
the nces landfill is currently permitted
to operate through 2026
and the mount carberry landfill is
currently uh permitted i believe to
operate through 2025.
i should note that any one of those
landfills
is at liberty to
submit a permit an application for a
permit to expand the facility and in
fact we do have a currently pending
application for mount carberry landfill
and success
to expand their landfill
and um
i guess the uh what i would also note in
the case of ncs in bethlehem it is my
understanding that
due to local zoning that limits where in
the town a landfill can be located
um they do not have a need
they would not they're not in a position
to expand the footprint of their
landfill beyond the permanent capacity
they currently have
thank you
um
yes thank you sorry one more question
with the um it looks like the turnkey in
the ncs
um landfill is coming to an end one in
four years
uh the other one in 12.
um
what impact will that have on the state
uh and and the uh
constituents of new hampshire and how
will it affect uh could possibly i know
you probably can't answer this but how
will it possibly affect their property
taxes
okay
sure thanks uh sorry so and
ncs it sounds like it doesn't have any
options based on their footprint is what
i'm kind of understanding from you and i
mean and this is subjective so it's not
you know
a hard fast rule how will that affect
the towns that
bring their waste
to that landfill and those communities
and if they were to go to mount carbury
or turnkey
would that affect
their ability to
even though mount carbury has been just
approved to expand
would that probably
decrease the time
that they have um
to operate
it shut me off it was tired of listening
to me
it happens a lot um
so the uh
um
mount carburyland i'm sorry could you
repeat the question again
if ncs were to close because based on
the what you the information you just
prescribed to us with the zoning
ordinance and stuff
how if those uh towns that are bringing
their waste to
ncs
and they had to find an alternative
which would probably be mount carbury or
the turnkey
how will would that affect their
capacity
i know that mount harbor you said just
expand get an expansion
but um
not knowing you know
do you want you understand what i'm
saying so i do yeah thank you for
repeating that uh it's a somewhat
complicated question because the way we
permit landfill capacity in the state
we
must conduct a public benefit
determination to ensure that any
proposed expansion of an existing
landfill will provide a substantial
public benefit to the people of the
state
and part of that and now a key part of
that analysis determining whether
there's a capacity shortfall that would
be satisfied by the landfill
and so
when we permit these landfills if we if
we approve an expansion permit
we actually
in order to ensure that the facility
provides a public benefit we specify a
particular number of years that the
landfill is to operate and provide
capacity for new hampshire waste
and typically we would put a
total
tonnage limit per year how much waste
they could accept
in practice what often happens not
necessarily always so it depends on the
landfill and the decisions that the
operators of the landfill make about how
they want to run the landfill but in
practice what often happens is that
however much
in-state waste they take
if
once they if they have excess capacity
beyond what is needed to provide for
that in-state waste disposal they will
often take waste from elsewhere from out
of state
so to the extent that a landfill that
the landfill facilities that you
described would choose to operate by
using all their allotted capacity each
year
it's not clear that um
uh
that that
it would make any difference i guess so
so if what it would mean is so if if
suddenly there's more in-state waste
that knows that needs to go to that
landfill and the landfill operators
chose to use their maximum capacity for
the year
they could take whatever is provided for
in-state and then the rest could be
supplemented without estate waste so it
may not have an actual impact on the
amount of capacity that's available year
to year
if they chose to
run at a rate lower than their annual
permitted capacity which we don't
typically see but it happens then it
could preserve some capacity yes
i also have a question can we go back to
the permitting expansion footprint
conversation sure in addition to
a footprint that sounds like a
circumference footprint is that what i
mean the actual lateral extent of where
waste is actually placed on the land
okay thank you and um one other
follow-up if i may then um to what
extent is there an ability for someone
to seek a vertical
expansion yeah in landfills when they
seek a permit to expand they typically
seek both a footprint increase and a
vertical expansion there are certain
sort of engineering controlled and
geometric limitations on
if you've got a given footprint size on
how far you can go up vertically
and so so if your question is you know
can uh can a landfill just keep
expanding vertically without expanding
its permit no they're
without expanding its footprint no there
are there are limitations to that
thank you
thank you director and i'm sorry oh
that's quite right i'm happy to answer
your questions um
so
if
so what you're saying based on
if i understand correctly
is that
the
landfills the mount carbury and the
turnkey
if the ncs when it closes
would have to accept in-state refuse
before they can accept out of state
no that is not the case
we don't specify how much of each waste
kind of waste type they take
um
we do require in order to find that
there's a substantial public benefit
that they do need to provide capacity
for in-state waste
but there's no sort of
numerical metric that specifies
how that's broken down
yes follow-up um so if they decided i
don't know i like the number 100 it's
nice and easy so say they decided that
it would only take 60 percent of new
hampshire refuse and the rest was going
to be made up of 40 percent of out of
state and i'm assuming for dollar
reasons
for operating costs
what would happen
if there was excess new hampshire refuse
where would that go
so
the expectation is that these facilities
in aggregate that are permitted here in
the state will be prepared to take
the waste that is generated in state
there there are some wastes that are
actually disposed of out of state for
private reasons that the generators that
waste make those decisions
um i don't ever like to speculate about
what the agency might do for enforcement
but obviously if
if a situation occurred where all the
facilities in the state were not
providing adequate capacity for in-state
generated waste
the agency could look at whether those
facilities were continuing to meet their
public benefit requirements and and take
some action but again that's not
something that we've encountered and i'm
hesitating to speculate what that might
look like
follow up
thank you um
so
i'm
the geography of new hampshire bethlehem
um mount carberry and then ncs which is
over in the the coast
um
with bethlehem closing
would that be added fees to get rid of
that waste if they had to go to
mount carvery or
the coast
i really couldn't say
whether the what the tipping fees would
be those are set by the individual
landfill operators and the agency
doesn't have any regulatory authority
over dipping fees
thank you
representative stapleton did you have a
question
i do
thank you madam chair
um
it's not relating to what you were
talking about but uh reviewing the draft
i thought that
something was missing and um
i'm thinking in terms of groundwater
drinking water which is covered under
rsa 485
dash c
we've referenced here
surface waters as
defined in rsa 483-b
and do we need to put in protections for
ground waters
under the 485-c
to protect
marshes and swamps that
are source waters for
creeks
brooks rivers and then maybe even
reservoirs as well as aquifers
that are not surface waters
but uh could be endangered by
contaminants
and i have not had a chance to look
further into 485-seat to see if there
are existing protections that relate to
this in the sighting of landfills
but we need to maybe take a look at that
and coordinate those if there are not
protections
for citing under 485-c
thank you um director wimsack could you
perhaps speak to any of that
sure i'd be happy to so so you know
groundwater protection
when we permit a landfill
when we look at potential impacts
groundwater protection is one of the
primary things that we focus on and
indeed you've identified rsa45c
does provide us with authorities to
protect groundwater from a variety of
potential contamination sources
including landfills
and actually any permitted operating
landfill
is required to get a what's called a
groundwater release detection permit
which is a permit that is really
it prescribes a
network of monitoring wells that need to
be installed immediately surrounding the
facility
background information obtained about uh
you know upgrading groundwater quality
so that potential impacts from the
landfill can be assessed relative to the
existing groundwater quality
and then
regular monitoring is required
throughout the life and the post-closure
period of the landfill
to ensure that it's not adversely
impacting groundwater so there's a very
robust system for doing that multiple
times a year those wells are sampled
and in the event that um
any um
contaminant a concern is
is uh
detected above background that triggers
an assessment monitoring period where
increased
uh more frequent some of his more
frequent and and and an
analysis for a larger suite of
contaminants is required to identify the
source of the problem and then once it's
identified to fix it so there is already
a robust
system for protecting groundwater around
our operating landfills
thank you follow up
follow up
so
with that
should we still
make reference not only to the surface
waters but to the ground waters
and the 485 section as well as the
483 section to make the bill
um
clear for coverage and
just make that linkage is that advisable
in this bill i couldn't advise on that i
do want to remind the committee members
that the agency is not taking a position
on this bill we're happy to answer
questions about the law and the current
status of how we regulate solid waste
facilities but we're really not trying
to to weigh in on the content or the
scope of the bill
thank you
representative coumtois
thank you ma'am chair thank you director
um
based on the current guidelines
that des is using um do you feel
currently
that
your the regulations in place are
protecting groundwater and drinking
water based on
what is in place now
in statute
yeah i i think that you know we focus
primarily on groundwater because that
groundwater is right there immediately
at the facility underlies the landfill
it's immediately you know it's
everywhere in the in the formation
and so i think that the protections and
the monitoring
associated with
um
groundwater are are very protective and
they work very effectively
with regard to surface water um
we're not again taking a position on
this bill i i have said to this to the
full committee before that
we do that's not to say that we don't
believe that
looking at
how surface waters are regulated and
protected under the statute isn't an
appropriate thing for the legislature to
be discussing we absolutely believe it
is
but because this bill and its efforts
could potentially have an impact on a
application that's currently pending
before the agency
it puts us in a position where it's
really not appropriate for us to take a
position on the bill
thank you
representative stapleton and then
representative bixby
for for my own curiosity um
do surface waters and ground waters
have an interplay and interconnection
does one feed the other or
or lead into the other vice versa um
just
question about hydraulic hydrology in
general
absolutely there's no question that in
general surface water and groundwater
are intimately connected and one of the
each one effects can potentially affect
the other in the given circumstance
thank you
representative bixby yeah uh i just want
to um
uh
make sure that the uh
just
the the intent of this particular piece
of legislation
is to um just address the existing um
or update the existing setback from
surface waters
which is currently set at um
200 feet no matter what the
geology and the hydrogeology look like
and it is um
so
uh
would it create confusion
in terms of that on setback from surface
water gold
to
incorporate something about aquifers or
marshes
an aquifer is really referring to
groundwater and a marsh as i understand
it would really uh probably and again
i'm not an expert on this but but i
believe marshes would in many cases be
classified as surface waters okay and
would they be
so this is addressing surface waters as
defined in rsa
483 b4
would marshes be included in that
you know i i'm not sure i'm qualified to
answer that question we could okay so
that's something i'm sure there are
folks at des that could answer that
question but i'm not sure i'm one of
them okay and that's something we could
look up in terms of just look at that
rsa and just consume it
okay
thank you
uh representative stapleton did you have
a question your light was on
oh
great
yeah just a moment i think um so
if we're good with questions for
director windsot i'd like to open the
floor to other folks who would like to
weigh in um and if we have more
questions we'll call you up again
and i apologize i do need to take my
leave in a few minutes so if there are
further questions for me
i would appreciate if i could hear them
soon rather than later okay
any other questions for the director
none at this time
okay
thank you director thank you
and if there's anybody who'd like to
come forward
to speak with regard to the proposals
for the language
or the bill itself please feel free to
raise your hand and we'll call you
forward
hi is there anyone in the audience
from any of the either the turnkey or
the
ncs
site
here
um
would you mind coming
thanks
representative contoir
thank you madam chair um
[Music]
could you just
where are you from what
what company are you with in what
landfill
sorry about that i'm with casella waste
management my name is john gay i'm an
engineer i've been with the company for
24 years and been in the industry for
about 30 years
so
i'm just wondering uh
it looks like that yours is the first
landfill that's getting ready to come to
the end of its life cycle and based on
what the director had to say there
may be no expansion possible for that
landfill is that correct
yes that is correct
follow-up thank you and how many
towns in new hampshire cities in new
hampshire does
your site serve
well we serve about 5 000 residents
across the state of new hampshire and
upwards of 50 businesses
around the state
so
do you take out-of-state waste also
yes we do um in 2021 i believe we took
about 14 of our total in
inbound waste was from out of state
about 84 was from new hampshire
so
um thank you um
with this new proposed legislation
um
would this have an impact on your
business or in your opinion
[Music]
the impact to the 5 000 residents and 50
businesses in state that you service
yes i believe it would have an impact
so
the customers that we
provide capacity for would need to find
capacity elsewhere
and the capacity that remains at the
other facilities that were mentioned
earlier
would be consumed faster
one more yep thank you and and because
i'm going to ask this this is a
subjective question um
but because you're in the industry um
with the closing of your landfill would
the tipping fees that the other
landfills possibly go higher because now
they're limited
i'm not sure how it works
yeah that would be hard to say for me i
mean it would certainly be up to
the facilities that are accepting that
waste i
my professional opinion is that they
probably wouldn't go up
but it's hard to say based on economics
and and what other changes might happen
in the in the waste industry
it does seem you know that that prices
are going up for everything these days
one more
and
just out of curiosity
if
your company were to look for another
place
in the state
how long is the permitting process
usually uh from zero to
open
um
i'm just out of curiosity
yeah so
i'd say it's zero to ten years um you
know by the time you you begin to look
at for a facility you perform the field
work uh
to assess the site uh permit the site
and construct the site it's ten
i years
i think i saw a hand too from
can i uh representative bixby yes thank
you for taking my question uh
so um
director wimsett mentioned that uh as
part of the permitting process
you there's a
maximum tonnage that you're allowed to
accept yearly and that can be divided
between in-state and out-of-state waste
if the new state of new hampshire were
to uh
improve the diversion of uh
things like recyclables and organic
waste etc
uh would you
then
fill up the rest of that tonnage with
more out of state waste
well so at north country we're permitted
to uh to accept 230 200 cubic yards
annually so that would there's a ceiling
there
uh if some of that capacity was lost
you know due to
you know any type of diversion you know
we would look to to back fill that
capacity for certain um
so yes i believe the answer is yes okay
thank you
i did have one additional question and
maybe it's not for you i'm not sure if
you are the design engineer or if or if
somebody else can speak to the
permitting process elsewhere in other
states that do have
hydro geological setbacks like some of
our neighbors have a six year setback
with hydrogeological
time of travel
how that might
how that works
if folks have sought permits in those
places and so
just curious
yeah i think based on my experience i
think uh the new england the northern
english states anyway
uh have all have similar uh rules uh
that consider setback uh requirements
uh in vermont it's 300 feet
uh to waters of the state uh here it's
200.
um but i think generally speaking uh the
rules are very consistent across across
the states at least that i have history
working within
including new york so
i think it is pretty consistent um
and certainly has been effective
in my opinion
so
and then there are some states that in
addition to a setback requirement do
have a time of travel consideration in
statute so can you speak to that
i i cannot speak to that i'm not sure
which which state you're referring to
okay
i don't i don't have experience with
maine siding
okay
thank you
representative
representative stapleton
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question
um i would imagine that even before this
bill that there are that you have
in-house or you hire professional
hydrolysis to
really thoroughly examine the piece of
property that's at target site
and they're measuring all of those
criteria that we're focusing on
how much permeability and travel
might be possible in the case of a
breach or spill or something
is that something that's already
well developed in engineering
in your company for looking at a new
site
or is it something brand new to you yeah
for sure i mean yeah yes we hire
consultants third-party
independent consultants um
who are professional hydrogeologists
that evaluate
the facility as i mentioned about 10
years to to
look at a site and then develop it to
the point where you can actually start
taking trash
in those early years the hydrogeologists
will go out put monitoring wells in
to understand the hydrogeology and the
geology
to
to give us information
so we can develop the footprint that we
spoke of earlier
so the site is well understood from a
hydro geological and geological
standpoint for certain it has to be
because the rules in new hampshire
require that
as mr wimzat mentioned
a ground water management release
detection permit
and that permit
evaluates
the siting for that particular facility
the groundwater movement the rate of
that movement
and wells
can be added based on
uh
a proposal from the applicant
a review of the applicant's proposal by
the des
and then subsequent changes to that
proposal
to locate those wells in a in a manner
that can detect a release from from a
landfill now i think it's also important
to note that today's landfills are
double-lined
so you know it's not like the landfills
from 30 years ago where there was no
containment system and and
and today we're still evaluating
contaminated groundwater based on some
of those
older facilities today's landfills are
double lined there's a system
in place to capture a leak through the
primary system if one was to exist
and then eventually if anything was to
ever get through the double liner system
that is what we're talking about with
the groundwater management and release
detection
so
if something was to breach the double
line landfill system uh the groundwater
monitoring network that was designed
based on the study done by the
hydrogeologist and the review of the
state
would detect a release
in the direction that there
would likely be a release
and then remediation or corrective
action can be
implemented immediately to correct that
issue
and as i understand it you know this
system has worked very well for you know
30 years across the state of new
hampshire and beyond
thank you follow up
follow up
so
it sounds as though there's quite
extensive study research um in in the
hydrology and the geology of a
prospective site
with that have you
looked at sites that look promising at
the outset but then later on with all of
the information come back
have you rejected sites or taken them
off the list
yes we have
and how how many roughly would that have
been say in the last 10 years
of searching for other locations
so we embarked upon a site-wide search
for for a replacement to our north
country facility in bethlehem i want to
say probably five or six years ago don't
hold me to that but it's been a while
and
we looked at five sites in particular
you know for further consideration and i
believe three of those were
were
not as promising due to
the proximity to
a surface water of the state of new
hampshire
thank you
okay
are there any further questions i know
that representative tucker had
had your hand up at one point did you
have an additional comment
yes i i was very interested in
representative stapleton's
comments and i
knew that because we had a chat before
the meeting
began that he was speaking about the
first line of the preamble
as to whether that should be adjusted to
including marshes or springs or
other water sources
and
it wasn't a general comment it was very
specific as a thought should that should
these words be changed and i just
thought it would be
good for you to know how directed it was
at that
preamble
as a time saver to the discussion
thank you so i see that senator
hennessey is here i don't know whether
she wished to speak or not
was there somebody else yes feel free to
come forward
for the record if you wouldn't mind
stating your name and where you're from
that would be great
good morning
my name is wayne morrison i'm a
homeowner in whitefield
i'm certainly not an expert in
solid waste management but um in the
last several years being in
involved in kind of researching and
understanding this i've
i've been on a pretty steep learning
curve i just want to in hearing the
conversations about capacity that you
were
raising earlier i just wanted to
reiterate that this bill
really has nothing to do with
capacity it has nothing to do with
whether ncs closes or opens
it's really all about where you cite a
landfill
and the intent of the bill
is really all about using science
uh rather than an arbitrary distance
we've been operating for many years with
a 200-foot setback
which no none of us can figure out where
that came from or don't believe there's
any science behind it
and
so the intent of the bill is really to
figure out where we can safely put a
landfill
the bill is not about limiting landfills
it's not about
preventing landfills it's not about any
particular landfill it's about how we
operate in the state of new hampshire
and when and if we need additional
capacity
how do we put it in a place that is
going to protect our waters and our
rivers and our lakes
and to do it safely
we were involved in a bill last year
that had to do with protecting our state
parks
and we we offered up
a two-mile buffer
and a lot of the feedback that we got
both from the
house and the senate was about
trying to be more scientific about
uh that approach why two miles why not
five
we've done a bunch of research and um
you know this is a this bill is about
putting science behind where we should
cite landfills and how do we protect our
precious resources in the state
so um i just want to reiterate that
that's the essence of the bill and all
we want
is to make sure if and when the state
does cite a new landfill which by the
way hasn't as no one can really remember
the last time we did site a new landfill
we believe there's plenty of capacity
with the existing landfills and the
expansions that will happen but separate
from that if and
whenever we do decide that we do need
another landfill we want it to be cited
based on science and done in a location
that will protect our natural resources
and that's what this that's what this
all that this bill is intended to do
and i would i would ask the committee to
think of it in that regard
thank you
representatives
yes thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question
so do you think after looking at this
bill that it does adequately address the
need for scientific approach to location
with what we've covered in the bill so
far
i do i think it's i think it's a great
step forward
i think if you look at other states
there's a number of other states that
have applied similar math in fact i
think somebody mentioned earlier that
maine in terms of new england is already
using this methodology i think they've
actually used six years so a little bit
more conservative
but there are other states also and
when when when you think about 200 feet
200 feet in some cases may be adequate
based on the hydrology of the site
in other cases it may be totally
inadequate
and i do know that you know i think
there was a comment made earlier that we
can we have monitoring wells and we can
quickly identify and resolve these
problems but the truth is
identifying the problem
coming up with a plan putting putting
mitigation in place rectifying the
problem that takes time
and the whole point of this bill is to
allowing us adequate time
to first detect the problem
and then resolve it before it hits any
of the waters that we're trying to
protect
and 200 feet does none of that
it it's it's it's it may be easy to
measure it may be it may be
intellectually very simple to process
but it can be totally ineffective in
what it's intended to do so
this is an opportunity for us to make a
very substantial improvement in the way
we site and the setbacks that we put in
landfills
and i think as a rational person
thinking about
landfill landfills are
at the bottom of the waste hierarchy for
a reason
they're complicated they're risky
they involve
you know
toxic
chemicals that can be released into the
environment
and this bill is an attempt
to realize that today we don't have
in some cases we it's the only solution
we have
but we should do it in with the best
available knowledge that we have and
this bill attempts to put science behind
where we cite them
and i think it's a it's a smart move for
new hampshire and it's a and it's a step
in the right direction about many things
that we have to do in the solid waste
business
thank you follow-up
follow-up
so
would it seem like the
200 feet
or whatever is an old-time
supposition measure
akin almost are picking a number out of
a hat
relative to the scientific methods that
we have now and should be using for
citing landfills
yeah i wouldn't claim to know you know
the details of all that but it seems to
us that that was a arbitrary number that
was picked years and years ago
and we haven't made we haven't made any
changes to it we've continued to live
with that and we know a lot more now we
also recognize that things like pfas and
other
uh you know forever chemicals that we
didn't even know about years ago
they are much more prevalent and the
more we know the more we should be
concerned
and uh protecting our water today is you
know with the knowledge that we have is
ever more important than it ever was
before
thank you very much
any other questions from the
subcommittee work group members i i did
have one other question um and thank you
for indulging me for the moment um
with regard to
the ability to see how um
this is
working in other states have you
spoken with
anybody else who has
similar
in your community concerns or
what what are you
um as far as the setback as far what are
you noticing are you noticing a trend
with the desires
to have this change or can you speak a
little bit more about that
well i would go back to my frame of
reference is you know i i got involved
in this um we got a lot of feedback that
you know the setback requirements that
we wanted to change should really be
based on science
so we went off and we talked to
scientists and we did some research and
part of that research was to look at
other states and i think if you if if
you do some research you'll find that
i know six or eight or ten states have
some form of or some version of
of this bill
and
you know i think
thinking about um the way we we not not
just this particular element of our
solid waste plan but we have a lot of
legacy uh rules and regulations that
have been around for a lot of years
um mr wimsat would describe that you
know his his agency has been for many
years underfunded understaffed and has
been living with a set of regulations
that in some cases are antiquated and we
would suggest that
this is one of them that we can make
step function improvement by by using
science
and updating the regulation to something
that reflects
the knowledge base that we have today
that we didn't have a hundred years ago
when that bill when that regulation was
put in place
that's not to say some of those
regulations may still be fine
but
it it gives us great concern that we're
operating with in some cases with
rules and regulations although they be
they may be large in number they may not
be effective in the way that they're
actually
meant to be in terms of protecting the
health and the safety and the well-being
of the people of the state of new
hampshire
and i think this in particular this
setback
um is a an area that would have
we could make great improvement we could
significantly improve the protections to
some of our most precious resources
by making a a change to what is i think
a
a relatively simple bill
the technology to do the testing and
understand it is well known
and it's something that we could
implement with no cost to the state and
with great uh protections benefits
coming from it
so i i think other states are struggling
with the same thing
i think the state of new hampshire from
what i can see
is lagging behind its neighbors
um
we're not we haven't been as proactive
i think it's really good news that we're
waking up and seeing that there's
problems here and we're trying to
address them i think this is a very
smart bill that that makes us
a significant improvement and we need to
put it in place
thank you
thank you very much
representative
thank you ma'am cheers is there anyone
here from and head
how about the turnkey or waste
management is there anyone here from
there
no
okay thank you
among the sub committee work group
members um myself representative contoir
uh rep stapleton and obviously
bixby is able
is not officially on the committee but
is able to participate but has no
no vote
right
um
but among the three of us are there
additional questions for anybody
here today
okay yeah no i can't uh i don't have any
other questions i wish that um
i do have another question for director
winsett but obviously it's too late now
but yes and are there
yes
would you like to speak before the
committee yeah you're welcome to come on
for the record if you could just state
your name and of course hi good
afternoon and uh thank you for allowing
me to speak to you my name is john swann
i live in dalton new hampshire i'm the
founder of safe force lake uh we've been
involved in an effort to
protect and preserve our beautiful lake
and state park from
an encroaching landfill development
and obviously as you've heard from other
people
our involvement in
all things solid waste has grown out of
our effort to stop this project
i did want to point out that obviously
the main point of this bill is to
address as was referenced prior
this old antiquated notion of a 200-foot
setback
from a a body of water
in fact i don't think anybody can tell
you
where or when that actually became a
part of the statute but that's the the
issue here is just like so many other
numerous laws that are out there
relative to
a shortcoming that happens in society
and then people get together to address
it
in order to fix that so that's what
we're attempting to do here
and worth the work of scientists
rep representative comtois asked some
great questions today relative to
landfill capacity and i was glad it was
very heartened to hear that
the expansions at mount carberry
have been referenced because
there's this false narrative that's
being circulated that new hampshire is
in a capacity crisis relative to solid
waste in landfills mount carberry
has a phase 3a permit application that
pushes them out to 2041 and they have a
phase 3b
expansion permit that would eventually
push them out to 2049 in terms of
capacity uh mount carberry takes in
about 90 000 tons of waste from maine
every year
so imagine
as you heard uh from uh joe gay who
works for casella at nces
currently
with their uh stage six um expansion
permit
they're uh
they're able to take in around 200 000
tons or so
from new hampshire
that could easily be assimilated by
mount carberry the only reason they're
taking waste in from out of state
is to help pay the bills so the capacity
is there for new hampshire waste in new
hampshire
but one other point i'd like to make in
terms of the costs for hauling et cetera
think about it the city of concord
is under contract with casella and that
waste is being hauled to the north
country does that make any sense
think of the environmental impacts of
all that trucking whereas you look if
ncs when they do go away and they will
because this town of bethlehem does not
want that landfill in their town anymore
for many reasons
why can't concord waste easily
be taken to the turnkey landfill in
rochester which takes in about 60
percent of waste from out of state so
look at that what we're talking about
here was all these environmentally
related bills before the session or
before this uh legislature this year
they're dealing with solid waste and for
a reason
so
our outdoor economy
our our outdoor recreation and tourism
economies
are doing so well record season this
past summer because
of
our environment
so anyway i just i appreciate the effort
or the opportunity to speak today and i
just wanted to address that issue of
waste being hauled across the state not
only from maybe concord but from
massachusetts to the north country which
makes no sense and there is plenty of
capacity with future expansions as
director wimsat mentioned so i just hope
someday someone will address with
director wimsat whether or not we have
an actual capacity crisis or
as we've alluded to or stated the ncs
landfill and the company casella has a
capacity crisis in new hampshire thank
you
representative
yes i do thank you madam chair thank you
for taking my question
so you just alluded to the fact that
sixty percent of
the uh capacity of turnkey is from out
of state and that is used to offset um
operating costs if that was to reduce to
thirty percent how would that impact the
state as far as cost
can you can you rephrase that again say
that again sure
you mentioned that 60 of the turnkey
refuse is from out of state and that is
to offset the operating costs okay or
profitability
if that was reduced to 30 percent how
would that affect new hampshire property
taxpayers
well first off uh as you point out
turnkey
waste management they're a private
corporation so obviously
at this point they're allowed to
bring in waste from wherever they want
we can't we can't curtail that
um
at the same time
in in looking at everything that's
happening in new hampshire relative to
solid waste matters uh you point
something out or you
allude to something that
our state really needs to take a look at
instead of trash being
a profit center
trash should be looked at as a utility
and that's why you have like mark
morgan's lebanon landfill
you have the mount carberry landfill
they're not seeking to profit from waste
obviously they're seeking to
take care of their their citizens and
their towns that use that landfill so i
think that's the paradigm shift we need
to look at instead of worrying about
the profit center for a private
corporation
um in terms of property values in
rochester i really can't speak to that i
mean that's something that
is obviously going to have to be looked
at but
what's the alternative to continue with
the status quo
thank you sure
uh representative bixby yeah
um i'd just like to point out that
this this committee
this committee hearing is about a very
narrow bill
and it seems like the discussion is
reaching out into a much broader
uh question of uh how are we dealing
with
landfill capacity in the state as a
whole and what are all the internet
interconnecting factors
and i think that
i'm not sure that this is really the
time and place for that particular
discussion and i think that it might
make sense to just focus on
uh does this language serve the purpose
that we want it to and is this a purpose
that we think should go forward
thank you representative bixby
representative complex i just want to
thank representative bixby for uh
reeling us back in and
thank you
um and i do see what representative
tucker again representative tucker do
you have additional thoughts that you'd
like to share
probably following on representative
bixby's comments
uh
i don't know that you've ever decided
what to do with the remaining
two
boxed items both of which
are in section b
and since you're focusing on getting
language to go to ols i hope
uh you need to decide whether you're
going to keep those or change those or
what you're going to do with it
yeah and that's a very good point i
think we had spoken about them last time
and i just for if my memory serves
correct with the working group we had
discussed the words adequate and
representative last time and i thought
we were comfortable with that
but i want to make sure that i well when
i saw that the
draft that
representative bixby had been so kind
enough to work on still had the boxes i
was a little concerned
i see because i just wanted to get it
either in or out
sure can you speak to why the boxes are
still there yes maybe
failure of editing
i could have read i understand i could
have removed them because we actually
did pretty much resolve those last uh
last session both are both we can take i
i think we i think we agreed at the last
session that both of those things and
most of the boxed
bits of text in
section in paragraph b
uh were fine as is and i think that we
also
uh
were
pretty much resolved that the box in
paragraph in
on the middle paragraph was now the
middle paragraph
was not good
uh which is why i have a strike through
it i understand
the preamble is essential i'm just very
focused on
getting it ready to go to uh
the ols office yeah so thank you
representative tucker and thank you
so i i'm uh other than spelling errors
which i i noticed there are at least two
um is there anything else in the
preamble that uh
would
uh it doesn't work for people
i did want to go back to the
conversation that representative
stapleton had regarding the water
surface water interplay
and my question to you representative
and to you representative contoir
are about the inclusion of that 485
colon c if you felt like that was
something
that you were seeking or where you
were going with that
yes madam chair thank you for the
question
i do believe that
from the testimony we've heard and from
what we know that
it is
integral
surface and ground waters interconnected
interplay between them
and i think we should at least make a
reference to the statute um
so that it's clear that uh there are
other
rsa legal lawful parameters that have to
be considered and you know it seems like
the industry knows that
and are engaged in it but for the
clarity of law and
and statement in the bill i believe we
should make the reference to the uh
585 a 485 c groundwater at least as a
linkage
and uh
when representative tucker and i talked
earlier on it might even be preference
with
and other ground and other water sources
or maybe you could say and other
groundwater sources or something of
similar ilk
so that it's
expresses our concern for protection of
both surface and ground waters
controlled did you have any thoughts
around this um well i'm just reading
here and it looks like groundwater and
surface water protection are integral
parts of the siting permitting um and
it's under and it says here under
environmental-sw805
surface water protection standards
section
and rules so there is a rule i believe
already in place for that
and i could be wrong but we could double
check with director winsett um
yeah since we're having a citation here
within the bill of
the 483
um
what
does it hurt to have
reference to the 485 so we've got both
surface and ground waters referenced and
linked
even if it might be stated elsewhere at
least a
single reading of this bill would make
it clear that we're concerned with both
i have a couple concerns um
and i do have another question for
representative tucker if you don't mind
absolutely
representative tucker
um
we were it was listed that there are
eight or ten other states
that have similar legislation
and i'm just trying to find out the
geography of those states i know maine
was mentioned as one and i was just
wondering about the other states only
because new hampshire is pretty unique
in its makeup because every single town
and city in new hampshire except for one
has water running through it and i'm
just concerned about how this will
affect
um
future landfill sightings that's all so
i'm just wondering about the geography
of the other states
i i
i don't know the answer to that question
i do know that maine
has a tremendous amount of lakes and
ponds that is the
state that i have actually read the
material
and maine is very similar
bedrock wise to new hampshire
and
i i think that
we
can be assured that there are good sites
for landfills in new hampshire
director wimsat has not implied that
that is not so
he does say we have a complicated state
and certainly for a small state it is
complicated
but
it is the
it's our job to protect the population
and i think that
almost all of us have had the misfortune
of living places where
they didn't know
what they were doing at the time
certainly the connecticut river is one
of those places i grew up in concord
mass the concord river
all of those the merrimack they all were
polluted terribly and the androscoggin
which has a mercury problem that's
incredible
after 10 years they still haven't been
able to implement a plan to remediate
and
so our focus in this bill is
to protect the citizens of new hampshire
the visitors to new hampshire the future
of new hampshire
and the wildlife of new hampshire that's
dependent
as we are mammals mammals birds
all life depends on the purity of water
so
i ask you to really focus on that
thank you representative tucker
representative bixby
i have a question for you representative
tucker um
so this uh
the text of this bill is going to be
inserted into rsa 149 m9
uh and
i'm wondering uh just so that we have a
sense of what the broader context within
state statute is going to be where what
does what does 149 m9 cover
i
are we actually going to mention other
rsas in here well no the just the the um
the the enacting paragraph uh
the enacting uh section says
amanda rsa 149 colon m9 by inserting
after
um uh uh
after paragraph uh
14 the following new paragraphs
and so this is so this text is going to
be that's where this text is going to be
insert inserted that's why we turned to
ols okay so
okay so that's really what they are so
so you're not you're not familiar with
the broader context
i'm not either no okay
i must admit that i've
kept a very sort of laser focus on what
we're up to here okay and i am dependent
on ols right and uh
the person who
works with this area right so the reason
i'm asking is because i want to
make sure that it would actually make
sense
to
figure out whether
adding a reference to the groundwater
in
c
would make sense in that larger
statutory context and i it looks like it
sounds like i need to do a little bit of
uh i think we need to
to to pose
if you could help pose the question
for ols to answer
and then in turn
uh
courtney eisenbach is in touch with des
and that's her area of specialty
so
that's i think the best way to get that
resolved okay thank you
representative bixby also um
149 m is quite a large
um it's
the statute is so large it covers so
many things
so um i just wanted to
mention that it literally talks about
all things related to solid waste
management
so
from
waste reduction goals all the way down
to citing criteria and then some okay so
um there are various subsections within
149m
and so um
i'll just leave it
okay thanks
and with that i do think that
you know i i
i do think we might have some drafting
questions here that we need to get
answered about just in general about
the inclusion of
the 45c and whether or not that is
pertinent or
to this area but i do understand
representative stapleton's concerns in
wanting to make sure that both surface
water and groundwater are addressed
right
so
with
that representative control do you have
thoughts
well i i sometimes think thank you madam
chair i sometimes think that when we get
confined things too much in legislation
we actually hamstring
the agency
that's doing the rulemaking
and sometimes it could hinder things
i mean i like to be as concise as
possible but as i cited there's already
in the rules uh the link between
groundwater and drinking water
that uh
chairman pearl
thank you madam chair i appreciate you
recognizing me just for the benefit of
the subcommittee and all those that are
here today and listening i've scheduled
another
final work session on this bill next
tuesday at uh
10 30. so it's but it's not going to be
it's more or less going to be a wrap-up
of the subcommittee so that you can make
a recommendation to the full committee
meeting at 11. so there won't be really
any time for a lot of public input on
that one it'll more be the subcommittee
kind of wrapping up their thoughts and
then we'll be going into a full
committee work session at 11 am to
to
take up the recommendations of the
subcommittees and to execute these bills
because i've got to move them forward
i'm starting to run up against a
deadline on them so
just wanted to give you all a heads up
of where we were in the process so you
would know and uh sounds like you've had
a
great subcommittee meeting and i
certainly do appreciate the work that
the the committee is doing here and i i
was hoping to catch a bit more of it i
got called into a different meeting so i
missed the first half hour but
i appreciate all that you're doing but
again i want to give you that info so
everybody kind of knew where we were
i appreciate that thank you chairman um
two of the
subcommittee work group members i also
did want to ask if you thought it would
be helpful or pertinent to ask our
committee researcher which i do believe
we have access to the committee
researcher as a subcommittee
about the
other states that have this
i would find that very helpful madam
chair
thank you i will reach out and get that
information
seeing are there any other questions or
comments from those out in the public
if not i'd like to then notice that we
are going to have an additional final
subcommittee work session next tuesday
what that what is that date
10 30 a.m
on march 1st so with that i'm going to
close out the subcommittee work session
before i do yeah i actually have a
question for chairman pearl uh
so um
in terms of uh the dra drafting and
amendment on this
do you have a preference in terms of who
would the who the sponsor of that draft
should be
not
not at this time but let me think about
that
i guess i'll have to think about that i
don't know that it's going to matter i
probably should be someone from your
subcommittee but uh
i i don't know that it has to be so
it definitely has to be somebody from
the full committee
so yeah
so all things being equal i would
propose that uh subcommittee chair
i think that would be appropriate i'll
take that into consideration thank you
okay and so with that we're going to
close out the subcommittee work session
and just so that we are clear
[Music]
tuesday at 10 30 march 1st followed by
the full committee at 11am
thank you thank you
you